Ryan Reynolds is one sneaky rascal in
response to a fan on Twitter asking
whether it was okay to screen Reynolds's
hit Deadpool for his four-year-old the
star offered a bit of tongue-in-cheek
advice lie your face off attack he
claimed to have taken with his own
daughters Reynolds is known far and wide
for two things and happening the
character of Deadpool to an extent which
may not exactly be healthy and his
twitter feed which is one of the
greatest compendiums of polarity on the
entire internet at least according to
his super fans the latest example of
this was prompted by twitter user Jedi
mind-trick
who asked Ryan I have an important
question I need an answer to right now
my son is four he loves Marvel I'm dying
to show him Deadpool but I can't decide
if I should or not help a sister out
Reynolds immediately leapt into action
doubtless convinced by all of those caps
that this was indeed a question that
needed to be answered with all due haste
his advice was as awesome as it was
hilariously irresponsible no put on
spider-man from 2002 and tell him it's
Deadpool it's what I do with my kids
remember to look him straight in the eye
when you lie good luck so apparently
Reynolds his children four year old
James and two year old Inez seen here in
2016 think he is spider-man which is a
pretty neat trick if you ask us sure
there are a few similarities between the
costumes of the wall crawler and the
Merc with the mouth
but how on earth does Reynolds explain
why he looks exactly like Tobey Maguire
when the mask comes off when new kids
could be gullible but that's just
ridiculous of course a quick perusal of
Reynolds's previous tweets quickly
revealed that his musings on parenting
and well most topics are never ever to
be taken seriously here's a quick
selection of our favorites my daughter
is only six months old and already
drawing I'd hang it on the fridge but
honestly it's absolute garbage I'm
teaching my daughter that the Sun Goes
Down each night because it's mad at her
probably gonna write a book on parenting
at some point and our all-time favorite
totally caved and tossed my daughter the
keys to the car she looked really happy
as they bounced off her tiny infant face
obviously Reynolds is a guy who loves
his family and screwing with people in
equal measure soon he'll have another
unsuspecting youngster to torment he and
his wife Blake Lively are expecting
their third child any old time now
little does the new arrival know that
it's
going to have Deadpool or spider-man for
a dad Reynolds had better hope that his
children never have occasion to meet
Tobey Maguire or they're going to have a
lot of uncomfortable questions at any
rate the cinematic fate of Deadpool is
still very much up in the air following
Disney's acquisition of the film and
television assets of Fox Studios
although it's understandable that the
characters r-rated antics might be a
tough fit for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe 2016 stead pool in 2018 stead
pool - combined to rake in over 1.5
billion dollars worldwide and the house
of mouse is unlikely to put such a
proven cash cow at the pasture the rumor
mill insists that not only is Deadpool 3
in the works but that there are plans to
weave the character into the fabric of
the MCU by way of multiple cameos and
Marvel Studios is upcoming films and
television series unfortunately with
talks between Marvel and Sony Pictures
having recently broken down it looks
increasingly likely that fans will never
get to see the on-screen pairing that
once seemed inevitable Reynolds's
Deadpool and Tom Hollands spider-man you
don't even know what he looks like
like what if he's looks seriously burned
I wouldn't care I was so looking for the
person he isn't music then again from
Reynolds point of view this might be a
good thing when his kids get a little
bit older perhaps he can show them
spider-man homecoming or as we call it
Deadpool high school let you have
parties you know my parents are dead boy
are those kids ever gonna grow up
confused check out one of our newest
videos right here Plus even more Luke
reveals about your favorite stars are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]